[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
previously on model lifestyle
[Music]
unless you
my
just arrived here the location
somewhere in the mountains
all right this is home
this is home for two days
[Music]
[Music]
cold misty Marnie
let's go have some breakfast
[Music]
good morning oh that's nasty
this is one of the makeup artists today
[Music]
the stylist for today hello it's me
this is the producer Yoga [ __ ] you've
got first place person thank you tell us
you snacks and what kind of clothes have
to wear
[Music]
this is the photographer today he's
doing all the cool photos
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the rise is the other model today and
I'm from Argentina
[Music]
we can find here enjoy with the horses
beautiful day good client so I don't
know even in China it's gonna be one
week if I'm getting it today just
everyone we can go for the contractor to
month
so basically years ten years eight years
so they still shooting the other model
here from Argentina turn on all right
all right so how done is riding the
horse here this is Coco she's the one
that got me here all the planning this
is really really awesome awesome girl
John camera hey guys so the morning
photoshoot is done we're gonna have some
lunch I'm gonna have some buffet over
here let me show you what they have
a lot of cakes Wow
this is Mariani might remember Mariana
from our TVC [ __ ] we did together
[Music]
alright let's go check out this side
kind of cool buffet place Oh coffee and
tea as long as they have coffee I'm so
happy
Wow nice potato beef here we've got some
meatballs
homemade noodles me how nice let's get
some food what are you having - for me I
should I'm vegan
I can't quick cheese yet by little so
some almost not a little bit rice nice
and healthy yeah yeah nice so we're
having some lunch here here's Mariani
she beat us here she was here first
before we just finished our lunch and
now we're gonna just quickly do some
makeup again touch-up then we're gonna
change and we're gonna continue on the
shoot and Mariani is gonna join us and
just something quick there's a
stereotype that most people think models
are not so so smart but my friend here
from Argentina he's actually got a
degree yeah what what degree do you have
an environment environment environment
is master's degree or a master's degree
man
so modeling is not who we are it's just
what we do I I have a degree also in
psychology and one in theology
[Music]
[Music]
okay which has been is the first day of
shooting what we finished early so I
still four o'clock so we're gonna have
some time look back yeah little bit of
walk back and we're gonna have dinner or
on six and that's it the name tomorrow
it's the next day today was a lot of fun
[Music]
so we're having we're having dinner
right now we've got a new model that
join us he's gonna join us tomorrow for
the photoshoot as well
[Music]
[Music]
now this is bamboo little bamboo how do
you say baby bamboo this over here over
here we have some fish if you look
carefully you can actually see the fish
head over here Wow
and some snails and then here we have
chicken but they keep the whole chicken
here with the head as well look at that
head you see that that is the local
alcohol that they make here in this town
[Music]
all right that's it and that's it for
today it was a good job
made some pretty nice people and right
now I'm gonna sleep and tomorrow we
continue day two
[Music]
[Music]